wendy williams is on the mend i said
what a source tells et that the 57 year
old tv host who tested positive for
covid19 earlier this month is on track
to return for the season premiere of her
daytime talk show on october 4th quote
wendy is home and improving every day
i'm doing okay last week after testing
positive the wendy show announced that
the tv personality needed to postpone
the new season of her show in order to
quarantine and get better a statement
posted to the show's official instagram
account explained that in the meantime
reruns will air no regrets it's been a
long few months for wendy who also has
graves disease before news broke that
wendy was dealing with covid19 the show
released a statement that she was
battling some ongoing health issues and
undergoing further evaluations
as a result wendy cancelled all planned
promotional events for the upcoming
season at the time images of the tv
personality surfaced online outside of
her new york apartment wearing a robe
and blue socks as she was led by hand
inside we've got a lot to talk about and
there's more including reports that
wendy was voluntarily admitted to a new
york hospital for psychiatric evaluation
concern for the ailing tv host grew
after she was photographed this week
vaping in a wheelchair but her brother
tommy williams says she's doing just
fine the show must go on
wendy would have it no other way that's
tommy during a recent live stream on his
youtube page he shared an update on
wendy's health condition and thanked
fans for their love and support i did
speak with wendy she's she's stabilized
she's doing all right i really
do believe and have the faith that
wendy's going to make it it's not an
easy fight it's not one that individuals
always win and
it's not easy this isn't easy
but it's necessary many times i come up
here and i laugh and i joke but behind
the scenes i'm i'm really
so thankful
[Music]
you